[Music]
so let's start with a warm-up
I can hear yelling in the background
that's just Regan boats going by we're
gonna use pulley this time but we're not
going to start with the POI because I
always want you to start with just your
body because that's in a way what this
is all of it so whether it's a boy or
any other physical like you know
activity or sport you're going to do
it's always good just to make sure your
body's awake so it just starts to shift
your weight around bounce gently move
your fingers and your wrists your elbows
and your shoulders start gently looping
your head and your chest and your hips
and your knees and your ankles just to
kind of wake everything up I mean
because just the way your muscles can
get tired and sleepy your your Niram
your whole neurological system it can be
a little sleepy as well so you want to
wake up all up get the blood going and
your body has to go out with something
going on you go oh yeah something's
going on we're about to do some fun
stuff buddy go some fun stuff and you go
yeah some fun stuff anybody goes okay I
feel ready to do some fun stuff then you
pick up your poi so what we're gonna do
this week as a warm-up is we're going to
go through basic mode so move it
so Sam you already know you already know
for the same time and backwards same
time and you know how to do some turns
with four at the same time and backwards
same thing now that's only one of the
modes there's also split time you can go
forward split time and backwards split
time you can try that now and for some
of you there's always people who sort of
pick up on that really quickly and
there's also always a lot of people
where they haven't done lot split time
things and so some people tend to keep
going back the same time and it's it
it'll come you just have to play with it
a little bit so there's a few tips to
that if you're finding it difficult you
can do this with me
find a wall or something and play with
drumming on the wall I'm using a chair
because there's no wall here in the wall
the plug with him to bounce the glance
off the wall you see it in the ground or
chair and hopefully that triggers an
instinct that doesn't work you're gonna
do this
take your both player1 play and I want
you to circle them you know keeping the
middle of the tether in place your hands
to be right in the middle or your hands
way out to the outside and I want your
whole body moving so you're not doing
this with the stiff body just the arm is
moving your shoulders are shifting and
your hips are shifting your your weight
is shifting from side to side so it's a
whole body movement but in the middle of
that is skillfulness of keeping the
center of the tethers in place so both
hands are circling the same sized circle
around that center point and backwards
you can do it low you can do it all the
way down here you can you come up do it
up here go really wide really centered
and you probably already feel that with
your shoulders so that's gonna be super
important because a lot of the moves are
gonna learn are going to be spa ball
your weaves and windmills
that's all split time
we can also play we don't just have the
side net wheel planes we also have this
wall plane in front of us so you can
take your poi make them a bit short by
wrapping around your hand you're gonna
go past your pinkie first and then grab
it here you get the poi coming together
down the center
this is opposites one spinning inwards
right to left the other spitting image
left to right you can also do this same
time or a split tongue now again become
split time let it be a bit let your
whole body be involved it's a bit of a
wiggle in the whole body if you do this
it's a bit uncomfortable so you want to
be loose with that same time split time
same thing split then you can also go
outwards that were at the same time that
would split time out we're at the same
time outwards lift up now with either
bows you can try this if you're coming
inwards
you can try feathering them together and
seeing how close you can get your hands
have you tangled today no problem it's
just something to play with see if you
can feather them together then coming
outwards same thing you can try
feathering them together we're gonna
learn that properly later on but it's a
fun thing that just try we gots do this
from the middle you can spin both play
in the same direction one way or the
same direction the other way this is
again this is just like we are doing
here same same time spinning but now
you're doing them on a wall plane in
front of you
now there's some modes I haven't quite
covered like this split time on a wall
plate in front of you but the first day
people can find that a bit challenging
so you can try it and the other way but
don't don't worry if that feels like a
bit wonky that's that's okay
what we'll come back to it and you can
relax with it today same thing on your
wheel planes
we've got opposites and I've got I've
got a whole video this week that's about
warning this so you don't throw that too
much now either so for now all I want
you to do is play with wheel plane same
direction the same time and split time
you
go to the same time to turn same time
split time same time to turn a wall
plane inwards split time the same time
split time and all that you can do it up
high you can do it down low you reach
out to the sides you can make big
circles let it be a whole warm-up as you
play with taking those poi through
ranges of motion and what's gonna happen
as you do that is you're gonna go into
places where your planes will go all
wonky on you and that's normal and it's
okay because in over the course of this
course we're gonna be learning to
control the planes and today you're just
seeing like oh wow there's all these
places who are I can't control the
planes yet and so that's part of
learning so just play with it see you
know and cultivate a curiosity but oh
cool look what happened I wonder how
that will be in a few weeks and the
answer is a lot easier but not straight
anymore fun if it's not fun today I
won't confined in a few weeks so have
fun today
Oh
[Music]